(dramatic music)
(gong sounding)
(ventilation cover clangs)
(train rumbling)
- [Voiceover] Okay, lady.
(dramatic music sustains)
♪ Come fly with me ♪
♪ Let's fly ♪
♪ Let's fly away ♪
♪ If you can use ♪
♪ Some exotic booze ♪
♪ There's a bar in far Bombay ♪
♪ While Mona Lisas and Mad Hatters ♪
♪ Sons of bankers, sons of lawyers ♪
♪ Turn around and say good
morning to the night ♪
- Captain has turned
on the no-smoking sign.
♪ For unless they see the sky ♪
(choir vocalizing)
(classical music)
- By nature of Habeas Corpus
and freedom of the press,
abuser of State-
- If Lincoln really
were a tyrant, Mr. Wood,
he'd have had your empty
head impaled on a pipe.
- Which may achieve and cherish a just
and a lasting peace among
ourselves and with all nations.
- Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Academy's
Visiting Artist Film Series,
FilmAid edition for makeup and hair.
My name's Howard Berger.
I'm a makeup artist
specializing in makeup effects.
And today I have the privilege of speaking
with the amazing and
talented makeup artist
and overall fantastic
person, Lois Burwell,
who has worked in this
industry for a while
and has done amazing things.
Lois won an Oscar Academy Award
for her work in "Braveheart."
She was nominated for her
work in "Sing Private Ryan."
She served as a branch governor
and she is truly a leader
in the film industry,
leader at the Academy.
We all love her dearly and
you know, it takes more
than just being great at
your job to be successful.
You have to be a great person.
And this is something that Lois is,
all these things, she really is.
So it's wonderful to see you, Lois,
thank you for joining us.
This is gonna be fun.
We're gonna learn all about
your life and thoughts
and all the magic that you
bring to the film industry
and, and to all of us in our industry.
So how are you today?
- Well, after that
introduction, I'm blown away.
I'm kind of disappointed by being me now,
'cause the introduction
(Howard laughs)
is so fantastic.
I'm all right today.
It's a rainy day here
and that's rather nice.
- It is. Yeah.
Very nice. Very nice.
Well, thank you for joining us.
You and I have been friends
for a very long time.
We first met on "Green
Mile," on "The Green Mile"
and you taught me a lot about leadership
and being inclusive and
working together as one
because sometimes being
a makeup effects person
and being a makeup
artist has the perception
of two different worlds, but it doesn't,
we work together and all these years,
you and I have worked
together as colleagues
and as very, very good friends.
So what I wanna do first is let's start,
let's talk about the beginning,
'cause this is always very interesting,
'cause you have a very
interesting start in your career.
You were born in North London
and which is thousands of miles away
from Hollywood, California, and I'm sure
at some point you were like,
"This is gonna be impossible,"
but you always attacked the
impossible with possibilities.
Let's talk a little bit
about how it all started
because also you didn't
begin the standard way
UK makeup and hair artists
and stylists begin,
which sometimes is through the
intense structure of the BBC.
You went a different route and let's,
yeah, share with us a little
bit about what that was like,
how it all came, came about, Lois?
- Well, the thing is I was born into
a working class family
where my mother worked
actually for the police as a telephonist.
And before that as a, Grosvenor
House, as a telephonist
and my father was an electrician,
a household electrician.
So there was never a thought of a career
that would be possible within makeup.
I mean, it wasn't
something that, now I think
it's much more know and talked about
especially with social
media and everything.
So there's an advantage there,
but when I was growing up,
it was something that was beyond
my dream or comprehension.
I started really when
I was at dance school
at the evenings and at weekends,
just a local dance school
called the Iris Caldecott School of Dance.
And when I was about five or six,
our class was doing a
"Dance of the Dolls,"
and everyone was turning up to rehearsal,
not looking like a doll.
So I started to interfere
and basically paint
the other fellow students as dolls.
And it just started from there.
And I thought, I really enjoyed this.
I liked doing it.
I still didn't think that
there'd ever be a career in it,
but I would just tinker
around at home and see things
that were in films that
would inspire me and think,
how would you do that?
How can you do that?
And just work it out with
a very simple stage makeup
'cause that's what I had.
And then when I got to a point where
I was about to leave school and I thought,
"Well, should I apply to the BBC?"
but I didn't want to work in television.
And I know that sounds really,
I think back and I think
what a fool I was anyways,
but I just, I didn't want to do it.
I wanted to work in film.
Film was where my heart was.
Film is so exceptional because,
and I'm sure that's why
everyone's drawn to it
because you sit in that dream-like state,
you sit in the dark with strangers
and everything in your
life stops in that moment.
And you are taken to a different
world, to different lives,
having a different experience
from your own life.
So that's what I wanted to do.
I didn't want to be confined within a box
in the living room, which is
how I perceived television
as being at that time.
So I started to write
to fellow film students
and offer my services,
working on films for free.
And that's basically how I started.
- Hmm.
- Now how did you-
(crosstalk)
Oh, go ahead, I'm sorry. No no-
- And so what happened was
the National Film School-
- Hm mm?
- when you left,
you had a union card, so
you graduated and were given
more or less access to
work, not the job itself,
but access to work because the
union was really strict then
in the UK and you could not
work without a union card.
and you had to have a union
card in order to work.
So it was a catch 22, unless
you had an "in" somewhere,
where of course I obviously didn't.
Anyway, what happened was
the students would be pleased
with the work I did, but it
wasn't just doing makeup.
I mean, it was everything.
It was everything from editing,
working on a Steenbeck
to taking over sound
when the sound chap went out,
(Howard chuckles)
for a packet of cigarettes
and we never saw him again.
It was all those kind of things.
So it was a real, "I've got the frocks,
you've got the music,
let's put on a show,"
it was one of those.
And when they left, some
of them got into doing
what was then rock videos,
you know, pop videos,
'cause it was the beginning of that then.
That's how old I am just
so everyone can work
that out on their fingers now, anyway.
They asked me to work on them and then
of course you experimented
and it was a time,
especially with rock
videos of doing elaborate
or extraordinary or different kind of,
you know, that punk rock
through to glam rock,
all those different looks.
So that's how I started.
And then literally I was on a student film
coming back from Scotland and we stopped
at a pub in on the way down.
Obviously I was of the legal age
to have an alcoholic
beverage at that time.
(both chuckling)
Anyway.
So we stopped at the
pub and it was a very,
it was the filmmakers pub in Glasgow.
So everyone knew everyone else.
And two chaps came in
and one I was talking to,
we just struck up a conversation
about filmmaking in general
and I never spoke to his friend.
And then a year later I get a phone call
from a lovely production
manager called Patty Hickson,
who's no longer with us, but
was a lovely woman, anyway.
So she telephoned me and she said,
"Lois, are you interested in
doing Bill Forsyth's film,
'Gregory's Girl?'"
And I said, "I don't know Bill Forsyth!"
And she said, "Well, he knows
you, because you were talking
to his friend, Mike, who
happened to be Mike Radford
in the Holt on your way
back from Brian's film."
And I said, "Really?"
I mean, I had no had no recollection,
(Howard laughs)
but he'd obviously
seen the work and thought
that it would be good
to work with me.
So that's how I started.
And that makes it sound
like you step out the door
and that's it, you're an
instant makeup artist.
The one thing I really
want to inspire everyone
is that a certain amount
of it is determination,
but it's also self determination
in you constantly work
to push the envelope.
I mean, I still want to
be a good makeup artist.
I still look forward to
being a good makeup artist.
I don't believe a hundred
percent that I am right now,
because I can always improve.
You can't rest on your
laurels is what I'm saying.
So when I started it
was just the beginning
and I had no idea of
where anything would go
or where it would lead to it.
Wasn't a thought of, "Right,
now I'm going to Hollywood."
that has actually has never
been a part of my agenda.
It's always been this job
or that interesting film,
this collaboration, this feels right.
And I think that to a certain degree,
if there's something I've learned,
it's that if something feels wrong,
then it's better if you can not to do it.
- Hm mm, I agree.
Yeah. I always feel it's I
never regret saying "No,"
but I regret saying "Yes."
- So...
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Were your parents supportive?
- They were supportive in that
they were supportive in that,
"Yes, have a go at that,"
but they didn't believe
it could be a career.
- Right!
- Because it was beyond
their comprehension.
In fact, there's a rather amusing story.
I did a film very early on in my career
with Glenda Jackson called "Gyro City."
And Glenda Jackson's a wonderful actress.
And my mom of course,
absolutely adored her
in "Elizabeth R," which
was a television program
that she was exceptional in and everyone
throughout the country was just
enamored with her and quite rightly so,
but I was working on the
film and mom said to me,
"You know, when you are
there doing the makeup,
do you actually touch her?"
(Howard chuckles)
Couldn't believe it.
- It's funny though. Yeah.
But it is important, like you were saying,
you need to believe in
yourself, but it certainly helps
when you have a family and parents too,
that help support you and
let you go down this journey.
So there's a lot to it.
- Mind you Howard, I
don't know about that?
Because there was always that thing about
"You must do something,
so you have a proper job."
- Of course. Yeah.
Even I think now, even
after all these decades,
people still like, "So
what, do you still do that?"
"Do you still make monsters?"
I'm like, "Yeah, I do."
It's been 40 years.
I think I'm probably gonna stick with it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Absolutely.
You know, in our industry we
do a lot of collaborating.
We have to, we can't just be an island.
And, just gonna talk a little
bit about "Braveheart,"
since that's the film that you
won your Academy Award for,
but on that film, you met
your husband, John Toll,
who was the cinematographer,
amazing cinematographer.
Great, great, brilliant
artist who Mel Gibson says
is the greatest cinematographer alive.
So, which is true, but it's interesting,
because you've done a
couple movies with John.
So what's that collaboration
and working relationship with
'cause he's obviously your
husband, you're his wife,
but you have to feel
confident to put something
in front of the camera
that you feel good that,
you know he's looking at it
through his view view finder,
but also you have to trust
him to present it properly,
in the way you see it too.
As far as collaboration
goes, let's start there.
Let's talk about the collaboration
between the cinematographer
and the makeup artist.
- Well, that's how we met.
I look back at it and it was very clear.
It wasn't like going on a date
or, or a romantic encounter.
That isn't what it was about.
- Right?
What it was about was
when you start on a film,
obviously I was quite nervous
and you want to do a good job
and you want to get the
character exactly right
and all those things.
And when I first met
John, actually, I thought
he was the operator because
he was operating the camera
and it was a makeup test.
And he looked up from behind the camera
and he kind of scowled
at me, kind of frowned.
It was my thought, I don't
like the look of him,
but actually what it was,
was that he didn't have
his glasses on so he was squinting
to try and get me in focus.
(both chuckling)
But literally, how we came together
was that, I mean there wasn't
time to chat on a film set.
It wasn't like we were
talking to each other
about anything other than the work.
So it was always work based and we'd go
to rushes every night, so
we'd see dailies every night.
And in the beginning, obviously everyone
was really enthusiastic and
there'd be like 35 people,
going, or 40 people going to
dailies to see their work.
And then by the end of Week
2, when the hours are long
and the weather was really inclement,
that by the end of the second week,
there were like four of us.
So that, and it was
always myself and John.
So we would discuss, I remember one thing,
was that obviously, Mel was
meant to be in the script.
It had him described
Wallace, William Wallace,
as being described as
in his early twenties.
Well, Mel was in his early
forties and he was directing,
producing as well as starring in the film.
So he wasn't getting a lot of sleep.
So instead of looking
all refreshed and heroic,
he was looking rather wrinkly and tired,
(Howard laughs)
to be perfectly honest.
And John said to me, can you do something
to make him look more youthful?
And I said, "Well, I'm doing the best."
But poor soul, you know, there's
only X amount you can do.
And in fact, it was John's
birthday when we first
started shooting and I had found
an empty packet of cigarettes and I put
gaffer tape around them and
wrote on them as little present,
"Instant wrinkles, guaranteed to annoy."
"Hollywood tested by John
Toll," and gave them to him!
(both chuckling)
and I suppose that's
how we began to actually
see each other as people.
- Yeah.
- Rather than as film colleagues,
but it was always about the work.
So when I've worked with
him on other things, I mean,
I know to trust him because
we we've trodden that path.
And in actual fact we've worked on films,
when we did "Captain Corelli's Mandolin,"
the two lead actors, not Penelope Cruise,
but two others, had no idea
that we were a married couple,
none, until about four or
five weeks into the shoot,
because there was nothing on the,
when we are at work that
would tell anyone that.
- Right. Which is the way to do it.
Yeah. You don't want to get it, so-
- Yeah.
- Do you feel that being
married to John and working
with him, it's helped you
with other cinematographers,
in terms of what a
cinematographer expects,
I know you hold yourself
at very high level,
you're very, very specific about things
and you always wanna
make sure it's brilliant.
So, but yeah, it must
be, you're used to John
and then go to set for
another DP and you know?
- Yeah, but that can that
can be a double edged sword
to be perfectly honest
because the people that know,
I mean, most people don't
know when I go to work,
who I'm married to.
I mean, I was working
with Steven Spielberg.
We weren't married John and I at the time,
but we were dating and it was almost
the penultimate day of
"Saving Private Ryan,"
before Steven knew that
I was with or Janusz knew
that I was with John Toll!
So, there's that, but
when you, sometimes it's,
"Oh, she thinks she knows
because she's married "to."
- Right.
- I mean, I remember
an AD who was married to a makeup artist
who used to come in and give notes
on how to make up people in the background
or small characters.
- Hm mm?
- And I said, "Excuse me,
where is this coming from?"
"Is this from the director?"
"Are you passing on a
note from the director?"
And he said, "No, I just
think it is a good idea."
And I said, "Look, you're
married to a makeup artist."
"You're not a makeup artist and you're
not the head of department, go away."
(both chuckling)
So I understand,-
- Right?
- and I don't want ever to be that person,
but obviously you have
to work collaboratively.
I mean, whenever I start work on a film,
the port of call is the
script, to read the script
and to read it as if you
are sitting in the cinema,
watching it, that's the way I do it.
And then I do a breakdown,
a technical breakdown of the script,
which I call the makeup script.
So it's, you know how I
mean, the day passes,-
- Right?
- Are they tired?
Have they got red eyes?
Is it hot out? Is it cold out?
Have they had a wash?
You know, (chuckles) all those questions
you ask yourself about
every single character.
And so having done that,
then met with the director
and seeing where our ideas
merge or if we can work together
because there's no point
trying to be the ugly sister,
cramming your foot in Cinderella's
shoe, there is no point.
You're never gonna get anywhere.
Or it won't be fulfilling.
- Hm mm, hm mm.
And then you let the film down.
There's nothing to say you are always
the right person for the job.
I think that's important to recognize.
So after that having met the director,
then the next port of
call is production design,
because I want to see the overall vision
that what they're working on.
And then it's the
cinematographer, before costume,
before meeting the actor, it
has to be the cinematographer.
- Got it. Yeah, no, I agree.
There's definitely the
succession of it all.
Yeah. It is, it's a giant
collaborative effort,
and even here in the United States,
there's a delineation
between hair and makeup,
but overseas, there's
not, for the most part.
It's one and the same.
And yeah, you need to work
with a great hair stylist
designer who you feel good about as well,-
- Yeah!
- because it all comes together.
There's so much that has
to be taken into account,
and then you have the actor.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Exactly.
- It's like you feel-
- And then that's where you all meet.
It's big jigsaw puzzle, that's
how I always think of it.
- Yeah. It is.
- And you're just a little
piece of that jigsaw puzzle,
but sometimes you can be
the most important piece,
you know?
- Oh, absolutely.
- I think that's true of everyone,
and the other extraordinary thing,
I dunno about you Hal, but
I've found over the years
that there's a kind of a confusion between
being a colleague and being a friend,
and they're not
necessarily the same thing.
People bandy around the
term, "Oh, my friend, this,
my friend," no, your colleague.
And sometimes you can be
collegial and work exceptionally
well with someone, but not
particularly warm to them
in any other context
other than being at work.
And I think starting out
that can be very confusing
when you are brand new.
- Yeah.
- And I think it can be
very disappointing too,
because in any artistic
realm, you have to be prepared
to take risks, and to take
risks you have to be prepared
to fail and to take the
wrong choice of a makeup
or take the wrong choice of a job even.
But it's all part of a
learning curve including, that,
and I'm sure it's been said to you,
and I know it's been said to me,
"I'm going to have you work
with me on all of my films."
- Oh yeah.
- And then you never
see that person again.
- Hm mm.
- You know?
- No.
- And then the surprise
can be that the person
that you've never, that
you were just being
regular collegial,
decent to, is the runner
who becomes the studio head.
- Hm mm.
- Or...
- Very true.
- The producer, you know?
I think that working
collaboratively with anyone,
no matter how talented they are or not,
I think you have to recognize
the humanity in everyone
and embrace it and make it a part
of your ethic of work.
Only because if you...
I'm trying to think how
to say this to students,
hopefully some of whom are going to be
incredibly successful, makeup
artists and hair stylists.
I think you can't spend 40 years.
I mean, I've been doing
it for more than 40 years
as you have had, and
you can't spend 40 years
being someone else.
You can only, because it's disrespectful,
I think to your own life.
And it's confusing to your growth.
It's very important that
you are truthful to yourself
as well as to others when asked.
And I think, and I could be wrong,
but I think that's the best
recipe for a successful life
and a successful career,
to be perfectly frank.
- No, I agree. I think
that's great advice.
'Cause sometimes I think we get caught up
in the inertia of it all
and you focus just on this
and it's bigger than that.
And your department, the film is bigger.
Life is bigger than just your department.
And sometimes we just focus on like,
it's gotta be this,
it's gotta be this.
- Yeah!
You know, it's also, I think
what you were saying is,
I find it's much easier to be
nice to everybody than not.
And you're right, you don't know.
I worked with a PA in the 80s
and he's a big director now,
and I was always nice to him.
He hasn't hired me, but that's okay.
(Lois chuckles)
- But nonetheless, you know,
but you know what?
I watch people in our
industry who sometimes
aren't very nice and
you're gonna be remembered
for how you made people feel,
and what they take away
from the experience.
And it's very important to
treat everybody with respect.
It's a very good bit of advice, Lois,
it's actually the best, you
know, it's better than like,
"Oh, learn how to do brows
or learn how to do this."
It's like, just be a really
good person, you know?
- Yeah.
- It makes a world of difference.
And obviously, you've worked with people
time and time again, who
value you on all levels.
And as a person, as an
artist and as a contributor
and a team member, cause
that's really what you are.
You're not someone who just
comes and you do the job.
And then you sit in a chair all day long
and look at a magazine.
You are a team member and you're
part of the creative team.
And that's something that
we really try to push.
You know, you're not a vendor.
You obviously have worked quite
a bit with Steven Spielberg
and on movies like "Lincoln"
and "Ready Player One"
and "Warhorse," and of course
blockbuster "Saving Private Ryan"
and he obviously values you tremendously.
And would you just
share a little bit about
what it's like working with him, you know,
'cause he's one of my all
time favorite film directors
in the world and I just
think it's wonderful
that you get to work
with him all the time.
So talk a little bit
about that if you would.
- Well, I think it's one of
the biggest joys of my career,
to be honest.
I mean, I have other personal
joys or little things
that I like about
certain things, but that,
working with Steven is fabulous.
And in fact, I was a huge
Steven fan, I mean massive
and went in, trampling,
the Queen's crisp packets
and popcorn boxes after
the Royal performance,
to be the first in there
to see "Close Encounters"
when I was a teenager.
I didn't ever think that
I'd be working with him.
And I tell you the first
job that we worked together,
well, I say we worked together.
We didn't work together at
all, I was doing the crowd
on "Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom."
I was called by the
makeup artist, Tom Smith.
And he said, "Would you come and do days?"
because someone, another
colleague had to go
and do pickups on a Bond-film.
And I said, oh, on Steven Spielberg film.
Oh, I don't think I can and
because my first thing was,
"Oh, no, I'm not doing that."
And he said, just get
your kit and get here
at five tomorrow morning.
I mean, it was just like,
okay, fine, turn up.
And it was just, I'll share a story.
I mean, I don't, it's not
something that I broadcast,
but I do remember that it was in the days
when there wasn't so much security.
So I turn up at Elstree
Studios in North London
and I couldn't drive that times,
so I couldn't afford a car.
So I'd ordered a minicab, which
meant that for the journey,
it probably cost me half my day's pay
(both chuckling)
to get there and back.
- Yeah.
- Anyway, 'cause it was
before the train started,
otherwise I'd have gone
on the train and the bus.
So it's not all glam. (scoffs)
That's the other way of saying
it's a contrast, isn't it.
And I knew we were shooting
on, the makeup room.
I got this so early, I got there about,
I don't know, quarter past four,
cause I was keen and nervous,
that the makeup block was locked up.
So there was no to go.
So I'm wondering, and I
can see just a work light
on H-stage, which was
where the Temple of Doom
was actually constructed.
So I just walked through the door,
walked through the stage
door and walked onto the set.
And I walked around and
the feeling inside me,
I mean, it makes my eyes
water now 'cause it was,
it was such an emotional
feeling of wonder and magic
and something so special.
And I was walking through the tunnel
and there were two work
lights at either end,
just so there was a dark bit
in the middle and then two
pools of light.
So very filmic anyway.
And as I was walking through,
someone was walking in
the opposite direction
and I stopped in the pool of light
and they stopped in the pool of light,
and it was Steven.
- Hmm
- So it was a very magical thing.
And he'd obviously gone to the stage.
I don't think he even remembers it,
but he'd gone to the
stage to look at the set,
to work out what it was he
was going to do that day,
because he's always prepared.
I have never known him not be prepared.
In the lunch time he's in
the editing room editing.
He edits as he goes, he's
there at the makeup call
editing, before the days
to start the day shooting.
He is a genius in that
he gets, he has a plan.
He has a vision in his
head and you are doing it
in that next moment.
But if something doesn't
work like the gimbal
on the landing craft, the
first day shooting on the beach
in "Saving Private Ryan,"
the gimbal wasn't working.
So he just turned around
and changed the shot,
change what he was going to do
and can be innovative in that way.
He can think faster than
anyone else I know of
on a film set and come
up with something else.
And you have to work to keep up with that.
And when you present an idea
and he's really open to ideas
and you don't wanna get in
the way and he doesn't really
like makeup and hair
faffing around on the set,
that's how he sees it.
(Howard chuckles)
I mean, he wants the work done,
but somehow it's got to be
invisibly done by fairies
rather than practically gluing a beard on.
I mean the amount of
time in the beginning,
I was just terrified, 'cause it would be,
"Makeup, hey, get out," you know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
- That's how it would be.
And you know, I'd be shaking in my shoes,
but then I just learned
that you just duck and dive.
So I'd just dip out of vision.
And then when he'd turn around to look
in the opposite direction,
I'd just pop up again.
(Lois chortles)
And you learn to do things really quickly,
but you give him ideas
and he builds on it.
So it's like be careful what you wish for,
you come up with a good
idea and then suddenly
instead of it being a little hill,
it's now Mount Everest
and you have to climb it
because you started that chain of thought.
But the one thing I will
tell you is that you are
a better technician and
artist at the end of that film
than you were on day one.
- Yeah.
And the thing I love
about Steven, best of all,
I mean, he is wonderful with
old people and children.
He really is.
I mean, he's incredibly patient
and terribly kind actually.
But when something goes right on that set
and you've got the take, even if it's been
Billy Goat Gruff before
then, and it's been
slightly kind of impatient
and it's all been a bit
on the set bit stressful and everything,
but you get that shot and it's like,
"Yes, yes, we've got it!"
And he's like a nine
year old or the first day
on the first film he's ever directed.
And that's, it's wonderful to behold.
- Yeah, yup.
- And to be a part of that magic,
even in a small way is fabulous.
- Hm mm. Well I mean he truly loves film.
- Yeah.
- And that's something else,
I'm always surprised
when we have colleagues
and from any department and they go,
"I'm not really into watching movie,
I'm not a big movie fan or watch movies."
And I'm like, what are you doing this for?
- Yeah!
- The whole thing is about loving movies.
I know you and I are
constantly texting each other,
"Okay, I watched five movies tonight."
"What did you watch?"
We're movie fanatics.
We're cinephiles and I know he is too.
And when you talk about
him being resourceful,
I mean, look at "Jaws," he
saved that entire movie,
the shark didn't work, so
"Hey, let's just do POV!"
And in our world and
every world I always feel
like it's the work that we do is,
we know how to do it, but
it's the problem solving
and we have to be huge
problem solvers, you know?
- Yeah.
- Huge.
- And that actually that's the key to it.
I think that's the biggest key.
What do you do most of the
day once you've made them up?
Isn't that it?
Well, of course that's never it
because it's like the fourth
bridge you paint one end
and then by the time
you've got to the end,
you've gotta start all over again.
I mean, that's the nature of makeup,
but the biggest job is problem solving
and it's coming up with
something and it can be,
I remember on "Catch Me If You Can,"
so there's a little boy in the hospital
then it's when Abagnaly, Aba...
Abagnaly, isn't it?
- Yeah.
Was pretending to be a
doctor in the hospital.
So there's a little boy
and he's got a broken knee.
There's he's broken his knee or both,
had some kind of accident
anyway, some kind of trauma.
And he said it in the script.
So I said, "Are we going to see this?"
"No we need a prosthetic piece?"
"No, we're never gonna see it."
(Lois chuckles)
See it.
So then Janusz, who is a diamond?
I adore Janusz as cinematographer.
He is fabulous and he's
a really decent person.
Anyway, he said to me,
"You know we're starting
the shot on the kids' knee?"
(Howard chortles)
I went, "What!"
You know, so what you're gonna do?
You can't let the set wait,
if you don't have a
prosthetic broken knee.
So I had to come up with something.
So what I did was I
cut up a makeup sponge,
put wax around it, bled
it onto the kid's knee,
dressed it with blood, and
that's what you are looking at
in a massive closeup.
- There you go.
- Not something elaborately made.
I once had to do a
lookalike for Prince Charles
on a film that had no money at all.
I mean, it was two bob and a toffee apple.
It was really,
(Howard laughs)
you were trying to separate
the Kleenex into layers
to save money.
- Yeah! (laughs)
- It was one of those,
and his ears wouldn't be,
and I didn't have the wherewithal,
a lab or anything else
to give the push that
the ears actually needed.
So yet again, I cut up, this is true,
I cut up a makeup sponge
and glued it, the wedge part
so that his ears, and it
was actually quite soft
and didn't hurt, but it
pushed the ears forward.
- Hm mm.
- There was a magazine,
I don't know if it's available globally
or I don't even know if
it's still in existence,
to be perfectly honest, it's
called "Hello!" magazine.
And they used to do visits
on sets and bits and bobs.
And it was mainly celebrity gossip.
I mean, but sometimes a big
wedding or that kind of thing.
Anyway, something that people flip through
in the hair dresser's.
So they came to interview
and I'm standing on the set.
And the producer said,
"Of course you have to go
through the makeup trailer
and maybe you would want
to take some photographs
of our makeup artist, Lois,
applying Prince Charles' prosthetics.
- (chuckles) Oh gosh!
- Yes, and the whole of my
life flashed before my eyes
and I thought, "O my God, that's it."
I can't possibly have
anyone take a photograph
of cutting up makeup
sponge and gluing it on.
- Gluing them back.
- Yeah!
- Yeah. Well, but that's
part of what we do.
Literally things, you
know, you plan and plan
and production changes their mind
and directors change their
minds as it's their prerogative.
And it's our job to like, "Okay, alright,
I know what we're gonna do."
Like you and I both have
the privilege of working
with Danny Striepeke who was
a great, great makeup artist,
he's passed on but I think
of him every single day.
And he really pushed the
belief and I do agree with him
that, and this is not ego-driven,
but we are the most
important people on set,
because we, he would
always say this, like,
"We're the most important
people!" "We have to figure out."
"We start the actor's
day." "We end the day."
"They come in looking
terrible, we fix it."
"There's a problem over here, we fix it."
"We can do anything."
And I really do believe
that because sometimes,
as you have done, our job,
which we don't anticipate,
goes into other departments
and we have to help other
departments figure out,
like I work a lot with costume.
I'm like, "Hmm, okay,
well, oh, I have an idea."
"We can do that."
I know how to make some
costume look all bloody
without using blood.
So give me the costume
and I'll bring it back.
It'll be fine.
But let's talk a little bit about actors
because like I just
said, we start the day,
we start the actor's
day and we end the day
and we always wanna make
sure that they feel safe
and secure and confident.
So, because again, we've worked
with thousands and thousands
of actors and we don't have
to be specific about actors,
specific actors, but in the
sense of how do you go about,
you're gonna do a film
and you have an actor
and let's say an A-list actor comes in
and he's gonna be in your chair.
How would you go about
having him feel comfortable
and confident and, and trusting you?
'Cause we really do X
amount, as part of our job
and then the actor goes and
does the rest, you know?
- Yeah.
- But ultimately it's their
face on that 40 foot screen,
you know?
- That's right.
- But you know, you have to-
- I think that, well, the
first thing I always do
is that if it's obviously a known actor,
I will bone up on their filmography
and I will want to see
them either over the years
or them on a screen and
in different environments
playing different roles
so that I actually have
a working knowledge inside
my mind of their face
with different expressions
and playing different roles.
So I can see, I suppose the
canvas, I get to know the canvas
that you're actually
working with as best I can.
- Right.
- It's a difficult question
to answer because I literally,
it goes back to an another
answer to be honest,
I think I'm just myself.
And what I don't do is I don't do
what I call fluff and fold.
I think that there's a difference between,
especially as a makeup artist, I think,
it can be seen as being a handmaid.
It can be.
And that isn't something or a role
that I would ever wish anyone to be in
or would encourage them in order to make
an actor feel better or more special.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You have to find the boundary of that,
but obviously you want to be kind
and if someone has a
problem with something,
they've got spots or
whatever it happens to be,
a blemish and it worries them,
then you are considerate
and you solve the problem
and make them feel better
about it, of course,
but you don't lie.
I think that's the most important thing.
Never be untruthful.
If you can't actually speak
the truth, say nothing.
(Lois laughs)
I think that that's a rule of thumb
and I don't talk about myself
whenever I meet an actor.
I talk about the work as
if the work is something
that is there that unites both of us.
And that's our meeting point.
It's not my personality
or their personality.
It's the work.
And that's, I think how
you create confidence
and an ability to work with each other.
There was an actor who
shall remain nameless,
who was truthful enough actually,
although it took a little
bit of work to say,
"I really do not want, and I
would not have taken this role
if I thought that I had to have makeup,
I would not have taken this role."
And I said, "I'm so terribly sorry."
"But the thing is that we are
both in service of this film
and we are going to need
you to be in this makeup
in order to give the director his vision."
"And in fact, fulfill
the remit from both of us
to tell the story of this
film through your character."
"And what we need to do is find a place
where you are not hampered
in your performance
by the consciousness or the
physicality of the makeup
and I can still for fulfill the remit
of the director's vision
and indeed the script."
"So we have to find where we can dovetail
and where we can meet."
And I could have been replaced
because they're not
gonna replace the actor.
They're gonna replace the makeup artist.
- Hmm.
- But it's very important to be truthful
and that's not ego
driven, it's just factual.
- Yeah, no, it's true.
It's true. And, and I think that's smart.
That's a good, another
great piece of advice is,
don't make it about yourself.
You know, you're there.
And there is important to
keep a line in the sand
between personal and business,
and I think sometimes that
gets a little mixed up
and you compromise the actor too,
because then the actor feels like
there may be a little misinterpretation
of a personal relationship,
just a friendship,
but you don't want to go there.
You're there to do a
job and do the best job.
And, and they are too.
They're not there to be your best friend,
if you want a best friend, get a dog.
- Yeah.
- And that'll be great.
Or a cat.
- Yeah.
Or a cat pillow like you have behind you.
(both chuckling)
But yeah that's a very important
thing 'cause I think also
people that are up and
coming in the industry
and in our world sometimes
get that confused,
try to dig in and become friends
and that's not what you're there for.
- No, and that can blow up so easily.
I mean on both sides as well.
Because the thing is
there's the give and take.
And there has to be a
point, even if you've worked
and I've been privileged
enough to work with
some wonderful actors on numerous films
and be requested by them.
And it's always a surprise.
It's never an expectation.
Always thrilled to be
asked for. It's lovely.
But there comes a point
where you have to say,
you know what, I know you want this,
but this is not in your
service in the end,
you need to look like X, not Y-
- Hm mm, hm mm, hm mm.
- because I think you'll find,
so you have to be able to have that ground
of professional relationship to negotiate.
- Hm mm.
- It can't be-
- I agree.
- oh, it's Lois again, doing it.
They have thought that.
I mean, I remember once (chuckles)
there was an actor in my chair
and obviously we've worked
together, you know, quite a bit.
And it was one of those days where,
gone now obviously with COVID,
the one good thing about COVID
is there's no food in the
trailer, thanks to God, right?
- Yes.
- 'Cause that's nothing
more irritating than that,
but it was one of those days where
we are on the phone, someone's
having a conversation
standing in the doorway of the trailer,
we're on the phone, someone's standing in
or popping in and out
with different updates.
So it's constantly moving
and then there's chewing gum
and then the headset went in and all I did
I went (sighs) because I've
got 10 minutes to do this.
I'm going to throw myself
out the window if I do this.
I was kind of up to here, and
the, the ear bobbles came out,
the chewing stopped and the actor said,
"What really upset you?"
"Was it someone coming and out,
the (smacks lips) chewing of the gum,
phone calls?" and I went, "All of it."
(both chuckling)
But that's being a person, you know?
- Yeah.
- And yeah, we all have
our frailties and yeah.
- Yeah, and, and hopefully
at the end of the day,
you do a great job and the actor is happy
and like you said, every job I end,
I can be doing a film with an actor
or films with an actor multiple times,
I never expect a phone call.
I just go, "Thank you so
much for the opportunity."
"It was great and best of luck."
And then if they call you,
"Wow, that's really nice."
It's a nice surprise.
It's just part of the gravy,
but never ever feel like,
"Oh yeah, I'm gonna be
doing this guy forever."
That doesn't exist. It will never exist.
- Yeah.
- So those of you that are
getting into the industry,
please remember that, it's
just, you're there to do the job
and do the best job you can.
Be super friendly to everybody
and all that good stuff.
I have a question, a
technical question actually,
now that now that filmmaking
has changed so much,
now that we're not
dealing so much with film,
there are some filmmakers
that still use film,
but mostly digital, have
you found that it's,
have you come up with a
process where you're dealing
with being able to work
with different skin tones?
Because also our films
are getting more diverse,
which is great, our actors
are far more diverse.
It's not what we are used to.
We're really opening up the, the gates
and everybody is inclusive
in filmmaking now.
Have you had to learn more
about things like this
or how do you approach
it now, in this world?
Well to be perfectly honest,
I think that everything,
especially with makeup comes
down to the color wheel.
I mean, that's what it comes down for.
You have to know what the
color wheel is, right.
And tones within that.
When I was first starting out,
you had to be able to make up everyone
to look in all different ways.
- Right.
- For example there're
stuntmen men who were little,
there was a little person
who I worked with regularly,
actually for a whole, called Kiran Shah.
- Yeah, Kiran Shah.
- Who's a great stunt
man and stunt coordinator
and a fabulous personality.
Well I've turned Kiran into everything
from a green fairy in "Legend,"
through to a washer woman
for a perspective double,
to an Edwardian child,
Caucasian Edwardian child
through to, well, I'm trying
to think the last time,
I mean, he's been a pixie, a goblin,
he's been every shade-
- Yeah!
- of skin tone you can imagine.
So I don't think that that has changed.
They're the arrows that are
in our quiver, of make up.
So I do think what's happened
and I'm quite relieved about it actually,
is that it's less, I think
makeup is more subtle.
- Hm mm, yes.
- And I like that.
I've always enjoyed and want to use
whenever is possible, obviously, raw skin,
even in film days before digital,
I like raw skin I like how it looks.
I think it makes people
just somehow subliminally
you recognize that it's another person,
not a made up person in front of you.
So for all those reasons, I've
always been a fan of that.
So it hasn't really affected me that much.
I think it might have affected
some of my colleagues more
that are more inclined to
foundation being their go-to.
- Right.
- I mean, I like to do things
like paint on freckles,
you know?
- Yeah.
I've always liked to do
that, to create characters,
those sort of things. So-
- Yeah, I know.
That's great. And that's the detail.
Yeah. I agree with you.
I think less is more, especially on men.
It's, really just taking, being observant.
- Yeah.
- Knowing your color wheel,
then knowing what skin looks like.
I feel like if you, if
you know those things,
you're good to go with everything.
- Exactly.
- And yeah just pay
attention when you're on set.
Look at the monitor. Maybe
look through the lens.
- Well then yeah. But trust your eye.
I mean,-
- And trust the eye.
- And that's the thing.
I think now of everything,
to be perfectly honest,
how I think that you can
technically teach people
how to do things.
You can always teach
people how to do things,
practical tasks.
This is how you block a wig.
This is how you block a beard.
Except that's really
not taught. (chuckles)
- Yeah. Yeah.
- But what you can't teach anyone.
And I've never known
it be able to be taught
is to have an eye, the
eye for either observation
or recreation of something, that ability
to look at something and see,
like the like native peoples,
when they did sculptures from a stone
that the sculpture is already
in existence within the stone,
you just take away the debris to reveal
what was already there.
- Hm mm.
- That.
- And that in our job is the difference
between night and day.
If someone has that ability,
that you look at a face
and you don't see the
face in front of you,
you see who and what that face can become.
- Right!
You've been a member of the
Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Science for quite a while.
What does that mean to you?
What does it mean to you to be a member?
Do you remember being
invited into the Academy
and what that felt like?
- Well there are three things actually
that all come together because
one leads to the other.
And I'm going to tell you
a little story if I may,
if there's time for it.
- Yes?
- When I was an officer and
on the board of the Academy,
they were doing a retrospective
of "Grease" and I was there,
and there were lots of
other people as well,
but there was John Travolta
and Olivia Newton John,
there they were, they were
like feet in front of me.
Now when I was, so I
suppose a late teenager,
I can't remember how old I was but,
but I went to see "Grease"
In the Odeon Muswell Hill
'cause I lived in North
London with my friend Marina,
and we came out of that and
danced our way to the bus,
to go home and as I sat in the Goldwyn,
which is the most
magnificent cinema to me,
it's the Mecca of cinemas,
in the row in front of me
was Olivia Newton John and John Travolta.
And as the curtain opened and you saw
the beginning of the film.
- Yeah?
I suddenly had this feeling of the past
and the present colliding.
That young woman had
no idea that she would
one day have her bottom
parked in the Goldwyn,
(Howard chuckles)
be an Academy member
and work in Hollywood.
It was somehow like going to the moon,
something that was unbelievable,
which of course, now we can
do, if you've got enough money,
you can pay to go, but you know, it's-
- Yeah.
- It was that.
So in a way it's always
been mystical to me
and somehow treasured
and beyond comprehension
in a way, rather like saying,
"I have an Academy Award."
- Right.
- That alone is so rare.
It's such a rarity and it's somehow
almost nothing to do with me.
It's an external factor, but I tell you
what is really special, I
feel, is to be in service.
I love to be in service.
- Yes.
- I like to be in service
of something bigger than me.
I like that about filmmaking
because the project
that's bigger than you.
I like it about the
Academy because it's about
the other 364 days of the year,
as well as the Academy Awards.
So that, I think it's a privilege.
I think it's something you need to take,
I take terribly seriously
and also lightheartedly.
I mean I always think that one
of the most important things,
not that I could use it now,
because of the COVID protocols,
but one of the most important things
I've always had in my kit
on any film I've ever done
is what I call the attitude adjuster.
And the attitude adjuster
is a clown's red nose.
(Howard laughs)
- I like that.
- And it's important because
you take things seriously
and lightly at the same time.
- Hm mm. That's true.
Well, Lois, this has been wonderful.
Thank you so much for your
time and your words of wisdom.
And I hope that everyone watching this
walks away with a handful of great advice
and encouragement, because
everything is possible.
Like you said about Olivia Newton John,
when we were younger,
we never had any thought
we'd be here today.
Like be really be in the industry
or be where we are or
be in the Academy or,
or all of it.
Just being in the film
industry is a privilege.
So Lois, once again, wonderful.
I love speaking with you.
Hey everyone, thank you for participating
in the Academy's Visiting
Artists Film series,
Film Aid Edition for makeup and hair.
Hope you enjoyed it. Thank you.